an age of male privilege where is mine
about privilege I've got no rights in my
kids I've got no representation in my
car though I've been locked up more
times when I got dinners
um uh you know I'd be treated like a
terrorist for campaigning I've been
um you know you know are they cater
terrorism Commander come down and see me
you've had work counterterrorism command
come down they're they're the terrorist
people who do it oh because all because
you're advocating for men's rates yeah
yeah and we put some overweight guys in
Lycra on buildings you know put Batman
package and so so it's crazy that's how
crazy it is so I
so I go to court yeah
um and then at court what what happens
so basically
um the father will be unrepresented in
whatever what's called a Mackenzie
friend somebody's there to help him but
they can't speak on his behalf
um luckily and why why not like do you
have the right to an attorney here no no
you you we would never advise use of a
solicitor in in the family courts it
would be it would be um solicitors are
definitely a significant part of the
problem okay
um are there any solicitors that like
work exclusively work exclusively for
men like we have a couple in the U.S
there is there is I mean apart for Mass
um you know I think there is one firm
out that is doing it but we you know my
view on solicitors is they just their
poetry and gang Keepers on One telephone
call Pearl their telemunds to stop
dads having access to the kids the next
telephone call offering false the
fathers and you're going to burn on
average 10 to 30 000 pounds
on a solicitor average because that's
what a lot of the I've had um I had a
guy named Destiny I don't know he's a
streamer but he he was saying how it's
really not that prevalent of a problem
than getting access to their kids and if
men would just see this country and man
no he's not
um but so I I don't think he was
speaking on that but
um that was one of the things that a
different attorney I spoke to
um or an attorney I spoke to said was
that because the other side will see
that and say oh well men are just not
fighting for their kids well that's
obviously clearly complete [__]
bollocks isn't it I mean look um
evidence 21 years over a million
inquiries and I've dealt with MPS I've
dealt with Chief constables I've dealt
with celebrity chefs I've dealt with
[__] rock stars I've dealt with
everybody really yeah
nobody [__] tell me there's no
[__] problem because that's bother
and he they're in denial or they're just
ignorant there's the other two things
there that's happening all right but
um
yeah this isn't just a problem here oh
it's yeah
I said I was in Barbados last year
and
you know I I would say I want to do it I
was also I ended up doing some work out
there and all these dads I was in a
restaurant and some people come up to me
go oh thanks for coming out and helping
out and you know I'm trying to see my
child and so it's a big problem in in in
the Caribbean everywhere I [__] go
there's a problem it's you it's a first
world problem pal it's in the states
it's in Europe it's in most First World
countries Australia have the same
institutional prejudices really it's not
unique how like why is that
well I think the legal systems all tend
to copy each other very similar but I
think if you look at the bureaucratic
command structure it's what Gorbachev
called basically like the institution of
government the civil services as we call
it is that they are embedded with a
particular type of our geologically
driven person and they tend to be
feminists and they tend to be people who
have a view which is generally anti-mail
father phobic which says that basically
all men are a risk to their children all
men are violent and all men have to be
treated in this kind of way what they're
trying to do what they have done aren't
women more violent towards their kids
than men well most majority of abuse
perpetrating on children is my
grandchild yeah so I mean that's that's
not even is the irony and and of course
if you look at domestic abuse if you
look at last British crime survey which
I think was for 2019 one in three
domestic abuse victims are men
and that will be massively underreported
because the stigma and shame attached to
men reporting domestic abuse I mean so
that's another well and they don't talk
about how a lot of times the girls hit
first yeah how are you if if you hit
first you're just beating each other at
that point you could argue that he's
defending himself I I would never hit a
man and then cry when he hits him back
what do you expect to happen like
is that well that that would be a fairly
Common Sense approach but common sense
is does not exist in the family and so
in if so he goes to court you advise him
don't waste your money
represent yourself get good help and
advice for a fraction of cost an advice
either from father to Justice or from
somebody else who other groups out there
but don't don't do the barristers
because they're because they're they're
kind of on the woman's side anyway
the solicitors David support share care
so what you're looking for your
solicitor who you're paying stupid sums
of money will not support what you're
asking for they will not tell you it's
the biggest show I had the third of my
casework involves uh very expensive
cases with dads are spent you know 60
100 200k on solicitors
and they've not been told what's going
to happen to them so for example
you know we would say avoid the fact
finder here if you can avoid it
um but they need they don't tell you
what the cost implication is going to be
but on an average case minimum you're
going to spend 10 to 30. there's more
likely to be 30. and in reality it's
going to be significantly more than that
our duty of care and that's pounds right
yeah in the US that's probably like 30
that's like 40 or yeah yeah so our duty
cares when I speak to a dad is we tell
them as it is we give them home truths
because they don't like it a lot of the
time but I'd rather tell you the truth
and I'd rather tell you what's going to
happen
and prepare you for that so you prepare
for the worst type for the best plan for
the best but you've got to know what's
coming down align to you but if a
solicitor told you it was going to
happen to you you wouldn't give any
money at all
that's why I won't tell you what's
likely to happen so they don't have they
don't have an interest in helping you
because they're trying to make money I
mean ever I mean in a way everyone has
to make money but but there's it's
different because they're getting most
of their money from the women yeah like
so why would they why would they help
someone that's not their customer well
but they'd expect you to pay so what the
dab will do the dab will tap into a
savings for example
um if I had actually honestly a number
of cases you get
men come to me I've spent yeah all this
money on solicitors or say for example
I've got divorce a lot of good Dads get
divorced the solicitors say well yeah
Mr Santa said we'll deal with a divorce
first then and um you know we'll just
get there you know deal with that and so
they get divorced deal with the finances
and then the wife's sitting in the house
she's got the kids got the cash
and then she stops and seeing her kids
it's all sorted
oh there's a little bit we didn't tell
you about you need to get a charter
agency to see your children
and how can you get divorce if you don't
know what the division split of time
between you and the mother is for the
children because divorce is based on
need so if you're seeing the children on
the one week on one week off basis all
right 50 50 then you'll need would be
equal and therefore you'd have a more
Equitable division of the Assets in a
divorce so the whole time
you know the dads are literally leaping
off the cliffs like that means because
they're believing what the solicitor
tells them and you just I'm afraid in
this one particular area of law which is
a kind of dark stagnant horrible
Backwater of the British legal system
this is the one area you would not rely
on a solicitor I say they will support
you like the Rope supports the hanging
man avoid so they avoid they avoid the
solicitors and quote well they run out
of money they run out of money yeah and
then they end up doing themselves yeah
and then so in court how what percent of
the cases do they get any custody would
you guess well we get are our track
record is about we either 70 to 80
success in either reuniting children and
fathers over what percent 70 to 80 oh
wow 70 to 80 success rate okay so where
we're dealing with uh cases where
um we're involved with managing
we can either get contact restarted in
most cases not always we're not miracle
workers we haven't got a Magic Woman got
a silver bullet we can you know [__] out
a problem but most cases
um that we're involved in with it where
we manage the case that's important
um yeah we have a higher track record
and we have a hard track level getting
share care and you and you get men all
the men that come to you have no contact
with their kids no some men have got
contacts some men are looking to
increase the contact
some men yeah it was a guy the other day
I was chatting towards chatting on a
Sunday morning actually and he had you
know sat in his hands for a few years he
was getting I think he's getting one day
one night a week and he lived in
proximity it might be should have been
having share care but what happened is
the children got older his daughter was
16 and she stopped coming she stopped
seeing him and she's too old now because
the court won't make an order for a
child over the age of 16. so he left it
trying to thinking that you know he
could reason with the mother that things
would improve and unfortunately the
direction of travel is the longer you
leave it the worse it simply gets you
can only reason with reasonable people
that's why I say and most mothers let me
tell you are not going to be reasonable
right for the reasons I've stated and
the more desperate you are the more you
beg to see your children the more that
empowers the mother the mother will feed
off it feed off it she'll feed off your
desperation and that's why I say that in
some cases you've got no contact you're
gonna have a choice but to go to court
but we're also very keen on Dad's
enforcing their parental rights
responsibilities because a lot of dads
don't and the other thing we often do is
we do like gdpr requests which is a data
protection request to schools or
subjects requests local authority to get
information about their children because
a lot of dads will only see the top 10
of the iceberg they won't see the other
night percent of what's going on with
their kids beneath the water lines
there's a lot of things that we advise a
lot of protocols we follow what per sec
of your cases can you get 50 50 custody
in and what would you say uh just in the
general court I think it's about only 10
okay I mean ours ours is probably 20 25.
wow so even like being we can't get it
but it's a struggle and I'm going to be
honest with you it's sometimes a
struggle because of the doubt
the dads could sometimes be a problem
um and I've got to be on I had a case
last year where the dad was yeah wanted
to wanted to attack the mother
and was like and we're going you can't
do you just can't do this right the best
thing we can do
is forget yeah if you've got anger with
them against the mother hey nobody
understands them with me but you've got
a pocket at one side this is not the
environment to be going off if you think
that something's unjust and it's like
yeah it will fit you out for a Superman
outfit and put you on [__] Batman and
Palace right but you don't risk your
contact with your child in this case we
said
let's get into court we've got a great
opportunity here to get a one week on
one week off order we went into court
my friend to string him up by his
[__] testicles outside on a Lamppost
if he didn't follow the instructions in
a nicest possible way I said if you
follow our instructions we're confident
he followed the instructions great guy
he followed the instructions going to
court mother's Barrister who didn't know
the case at all
the judge said because we dropped
drafted up what's called a consent order
so we'd ran all the order out for the
judge
saying 50 50 and they're just going this
is amazing this is a really good order I
think this is really good so he said the
mind was back I said what do you think
of well I think it's a very good order
slam dunk
walked out 50 50. share care live with
my parents order
Victory that's what we want but that
should be the standard that we have to
work so hard
so hard to get those cases overnight so
it's like
if so if if a guy makes a kid or has a
kid with a crazy lady right that's a lot
there's a lot of that going on yeah I
know there's a lot of that going on
and
so essentially if he wants to see his
kid he I just want to make sure I
understand it so he he first
um he he shouldn't leave the house but
often he usually does stay in the
property paying the property now what
you should do if he's in the house is
you should draft what's called a living
together arrangements so you work out uh
you know you give undertakings not to
make allegations against the other
person you agree a rotor for use of the
rooms the bathroom the kitchen spending
time with the children
and you agree that you know uh between
you or you get solicitor to ratify us at
one point you might use a solicitor for
is is if you're still in the property to
agree you're living together arrangement
while you're still in the property you
apply for a live with both parents order
right and that's important you do it
while you're still living with the
children and you make that application
so you do those two things
and that means that if you are removed
from the property you leave the property
at least if you've got an order in place
then that's going to protect your
relationship with the children what
tends to happen Pearl is this if you're
living together and I want to get rid of
you she will call the police
make an allegation that you pushed her
no police will come and arrest you and
then bail you not to return to the
property
that's one more game with you the other
way is when you're out
they change the locks and it gets less
on board and they get what's called a
um a non-monestation order and they're
giving out like confetti and she says
I've suffered years of abuse and harm
and he's terrible he's done this doesn't
again no no evidence required just say
and the court will give her a
non-molestation order for the farmer not
to contact the Marvel approach the book
given 100 100 yards or whatever
so again another way of removing the
father from the home really easy this is
really straight this happens every day
um and it'll change the locks to change
the locks which is unlawful because if
it's your home but nobody gives a [__]
um so the father's easily removed from
the property so if you're in the
property we say avoid all arguments
avoidable disputes get a living together
Arrangement work it out and get your
application in straight away for a
little bit by parents order what then
tends to happen if you get your
non-molestation order a lot of dads get
upset about it I want to defend their
reputation forget it because the
non-molar station order in 99.9 cases
will remain in place because that's the
course
presumption but what you've got to bear
in mind with normal station order
maximum five years inside for a breach
five years in sight so a bridge for
breach for con if you contact the mother
or use a third party to contact a mother
you risk five five years of jail five
years of jail
shut up so here he doesn't even have the
right to try to reason with her no you
have to go through she's got a solicitor
you have to go for this list there but
what you don't want to do is a guy okay
I'm trying to recount any stories
because I've got yeah millions of them
upstairs
um there's another guy who's a couple of
years ago
um we said don't speak to the mother the
mother was contacting him even though it
was in a molestation order he's saying
she keeps contacting me Matt she's she
keeps contacting me I said do not
respond it's a trap it's a [__] trap
it's a trap it's a trap as I said so was
he there
she invites you around for a Chinese
Takeaway
sounds great
he gets in there and he's chowing down
on his first sweet and South Baltimore
it's great it's a [__] feast
knock at the door
it's the deal coming
he said can I just finish my meal no
and he's like shoves a couple of Paws in
his jacket pocket to take with him it's
cuffed
that's it they've got power arrests
today
I had a case of a mother
who said the father had contacted her
and was in breach of the normal and he
was arrested spent a day in prison
but that was a old non-monastation or
she showed the police there was a new
normal station order allowing him to
contact the mama and she delivered
molestation order that's that's exactly
what it sounds like yeah you're not
allowed to contact the mother but she
used an old one to get arrested when in
reality there was a new one which she
hadn't shown the police which said he
wasn't allowed to contact her because
you know solicitor so again I had a case
of uh it's another rape so we'd get a
lot called fake rape cases I had a
mother a ledge again simply to destroy
the father destroy his reputation and to
die of access to his son
the mother alleged that she was raped in
2014.
and she kept a diary
written diary about these kind of sexual
assaults and stuff and it's rape
incident
and then when the because your criminal
proceedings can be disclosed the family
proceedings when when there was
visibility of this of of his diary
there were some entry marks of like sort
of 2018.
I thought this is a bit odd why would
you write 2018 if the diary was written
in 2014.
let's raise with the police the police
investigated
I found out the diary was produced
in Hong Kong in 2016.
two years after she said she wrote it
so it was a complete fabrication
and she was arrested for perverting a
course of Justice
she wisely gave a no comment interview
reverseless at present and sadly there
was no prosecution
but that will give you some extent
that's flavor
for some of the desperate tactics that
we say and there's no consequences
there's not and they're actually
incentivized to do it because they get
the free legal aid correct if they
accuse him of something correct and
there's no consequence if they lock him
out of the house there's no consequence
for tricking him into getting arrested
like they can just get away with this
and go to court and still get access
probably get 90 of the time they're
going to get access to their kids unless
they go against you well well I mean the
mother will get you know you know say
yeah 97 so it's it's
the entire system is completely rigged
you said 97
97 you know 97 by vast majority The
Residency is given to mothers oh yeah I
mean and I'd say we are successful again
share care but that is they are rare the
course don't like equality they don't
like this idea that that men should be
equal
but I said well I was in Pub address
last year
and I did this interview with with a guy
there and he was like it was really you
know quite he wasn't a friendly brother
to his other fathers I can tell you he
was really sexy it's quite quiet
demonizing dads as deadbeats and
feckless failed fathers
um it's a really common narrative I
heard it all the time growing up front
of Vegas do you know who coined the
phrase Debbie dance Ronald Reagan wow in
the 80s
that's where this [__] comes from
and then what every say the power
institutions in every country have gone
great let's use dads as whipping boys
yeah we're cheap political Capital so we
go create the idea of feckless fail
fathers we're all deadbeats who don't
want to see their kids don't want to pay
money the reality is right
the vast majority had in my opinion are
desperate to see their case the vast
majority of dads want 50 50 shared care
we demand equality parental quality and
yet we live in an age where in my
country I am reduced to the status of a
sperm bank
I'll reduce the status of a [__] cash
point
you know really
how could you do that to half the
population how could you demonize and
toxify
you know and make us reduce to this
pitiful status and then pretend we live
in a [__] patriarchy it is beyond
belief and that's before we ever get on
to the the fraud of the Rings marriage
you know and that's another institution
which is truly appalling as many of you
know I was just banned on Tick Tock and
we are demonetized on a daily basis on
this platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible